this morning we're kicking off our new
week-long series we're calling it world
of weddings so we sent a team of
correspondents all around the globe to
witness unique ceremonies to understand
what marriage means in different
cultures in our first report we're going
to India country where modern technology
is blending with centuries-old marriage
traditions Ramey Inocencio went to New
Delhi to meet a young couple who were
basically strangers until six months
before they tied the knot we're dancing
in New Delhi the big fat Indian wedding
and basically everyone you see here
who's married has gotten matched in an
arranged marriage about 90% of all
Indian weddings are arranged and that is
despite the rising influence of the west
tradition here is as strong as ever
welcome to one of the most spectacular
shows on earth but this isn't a music
video or even a Bollywood movie this
high in production is an Indian wedding
celebration taking place on the
outskirts of New Delhi India's bustling
capital city nearly 30 million people
amidst all the food fireworks and
fanfare here in India centuries-old
traditions like arranged marriages
remain alive and well
sumit Gambier is a 29 year old tax
attorney and Vani Mehta 24 just finished
Business School there were only
acquaintances but six months ago both
families agreed to the Union sumit flew
to Canada where Vani was living and
proposed you guys never dated never a
lot of Americans might ask is this love
I think for me it's arranged come love
marriage the kids in the six months we
fell into such a great place that now I
can just say you know that I love him
allow it I love it too
for many young couples in India their
perfectly arranged match might start
here at the headquarters of shaadi.com
in
by and upon Mittal is its founder in
India you know you we often say you
don't marry an individual you marry
their family do people find love this is
this is a great question because we're
gonna get very very philosophical but in
India it is a stage of life we go
through childhood we go through
adolescence and then we go through what
is called a domestic stage of life
before you retire the company claims to
have arranged nearly 6 million
successful matches navigating hundreds
of different religions cultures and
languages when we think about love in
India it's not necessary a chemical
reaction where you fall in love you find
love out of respect for each other over
time once the marriage is arranged the
wedding arrangements begin TV wedding
host Ambika Anand
so people have their family then
families family then in India is this
huge thing everybody gets offended if
they're not called for our wedding so it
might seem really large to a Western
audience because you guys have hundred
guests and if a hundred and one person
shows up you're like oh my god we're
already fitted for a small wedding this
holds 500 people got a slightly bigger
family this holds 1,200 and for a
blowout this holds 2,000 people that
includes Bollywood blowouts like this
one hosted by one of India's richest
families another was capped off with a
performance by Beyonce with an estimated
price tag of up to 100 million dollars
Vonnie and sumit sweating celebration
was a five-day affair
it began with traditional celebrations
for the bride and the groom
two days later sumit was on horseback
surrounded by hundreds of friends and
family as you rode into the wedding
venue nearby vani was decorated with
hundreds of precious jewels gifted to
her by family the Hindu wedding ceremony
takes several hours with guests hopping
in and out to wish them well once the
marriage vows are exchanged the party
begins what was the most stressful part
of your wedding
[Music]
a sense of hope at New Delhi's biggest
wedding reception hall where everyone
including the newlywed couple looked on
as a sparks begin to fly and that's
marriage in India s Lord divorces get
this only 1% of marriages end in divorce
in India compare that to 50% in the
United States there's a lot of societal
and family pressures and also there's
probably a little bit of love floating
around - ranee innocencio CBS News New
Delhi yeah if you spent that much money
on the wedding your parents will kill
you also no one's that no one's
arranging the divorce for you so do that
yourself yeah I don't know what
beautiful but I want to know is there
love there I mean I kind of like the
idea of a relationship where you're
searching for love as opposed to here
where you're trying to maintain the love
yeah but pretty clearly if you don't
find it you see the size of unhappy
people there